i've been waiting for like a good
masters of the universe movie since i
was like a kid
so are you guys still doing that film
yeah we are and we plan on it being good
yeah exactly i i have i have high
expectations for the two of you um can
you just can you talk about where you're
at in the scripting process and maybe
when you hope to be in front of cameras
yeah we're we're um there's some stuff
that we can't talk about in terms of the
approach but there's
it's it's all happening it's all moving
in the right direction but in terms of
approach it's like
we just we want to make a master's that
feels the way it did to us when we were
kids where like it's this like
empowerment that you get from it from
the fantasy of it but also like colorful
vibrant fun and irreverent like you
can't have characters like snout spout
and ram man without having some jokes in
there so we just want to make a really
fun masters of the universe film uh do
you think you'll be filming this year
uh i think we'll be filming in 23.
god okay so you're still you're still in
pre-production on that thing yes yeah
and and because we we want to give this
the the scale that it deserves you know
get to have an attorney that's the the
attorney that we've been waiting for
it's it's it's a big one to get up and
running but it's it's going great
it's huge and there's a you guys will
all hear some exciting things in the
coming months that are happening with it
um but it's very exciting and and it's
being done right
you